that's right brian and denise it really
is going to be an amazing celebration
bigger than ever and let me tell you why
you're taking a live look here at
resorts world
that property is the latest to be added
to a long list of strip properties to
really boost up the energy in the sky
the crews are still loading in they're
finishing up today they'll be completed
by tomorrow with all their testing and
all that so
we're excited so we can't wait for
midnight tomorrow the race is on to ring
in the new year scott cooper director
for fireworks by grucci says the
fireworks extravaganza will amaze crowds
from eight properties along the las
vegas strip after covid paused last
year's show
you know last year there was a lot of
guys you know
affected by kovit in more ways than one
and you know
just doing the regular things fireworks
by grucci pyrotechnicians like john
paccini have placed over 11 000 electric
circuit units along the strip from mgm
grand to the strat and adding resorts
world to this year's lineup each
programmed to series of colors lights
and sound effects they start planning
this months and months in advance but
when we get out here it's usually about
four to five days of setup of testing
and everything you know we have to bring
the equipment down from the ground level
up the deuces wild is this year's theme
with a countdown rushing up the strat
tower and a hot soundtrack to help you
groove
every year we say after the smoke clears
from this one how do we beat what we did
the last year you know how do we make it
that much better
and it is it's a challenge
all right back out here live we did
mention about the soundtrack to that
eight minute long fireworks show well it
includes artists like aerosmith taylor
swift diana ross and pitbull and brian
let me tell you
i looked up your request for the
aerosmith song and it's actually deuces
are wild which goes perfectly hand in
hand with this year's theme christian
cassette is live local now